hallo
herzlich willkommen in meinen taten welt
heute mache ich einen käsekuchen mit
schokostreuseln und diesen guten werde
ich heute im thermomix zu bereiten
falls ihr keine tricks habt könnt ihr
diesen kuchen natürlich trotzdem zu
bereiten daneben ihr euch einen anderen
mixer oder verknetet alles mit der hand
alles weitere sage ich euch dann später
jetzt zeige ich euch erstmal die zutaten
für den boden dafür braucht ihr nämlich
70 gramm butter 65 gramm zucker 120
gramm mehl einen teelöffel backpulver 30
gramm kakao und ein großes ei oder
eventuell zwei kleine eier den kuchen
werde ich rechteckig packen und zwar in
meiner lohmarer backform ich habe jetzt
da das halbe blech der kuchen wird dann
16 x 36 cm ganz normalen rechteckigen
back hand benutzen der einfach der größe
entspricht der körper zum beispiel auch
quadratisch sein dann wäre ich einfach
alle zutaten in den thermomix
dann kommt der deckel wieder und dann
werden die teils zutaten 30 sekunden auf
stufe vier
so sieht der teig dann aus und wenn ich
zwei kleine eier benutzer ist der tag
etwas flüssiger das finde ich besser
presse wenn ihr nur ein großes habt dann
gibt einfach noch ein schuss milch mit
rein
der teig soll sich ja gleich gut
verstreichen lassen können und so sie
daran danach aus dann nehme ich mir
meine trocken form kratzt den teig aus
dem thermomix heraus und dann
verstreicht es einfach schön gleichmäßig
auf dem trockenboden auf dem boden
nehmt ihr euch einen glas
schattenmorellen oder sauerkirschen lass
dir gut abtropfen und dann werden die
darauf verteilt das bereite ich kurz war
und zeigt dann wie ich sie darauf
verteilen
ich geb dir ganz einfach eben drauf und
dann werden sie so etwas gleichmäßig
verteilt so dass später an jedem
stückchen ungefähr gleich spieler
kirchenleben kann man natürlich auch
ganz gut mit frischen kirschen machen im
sommer wenn man welche hat aber auf dem
glas oder tiefgekühlte kirche auf die
kann man immer zurückgreifen also tk
genauso jetzt stelle ich das kurz zur
seite und zeige ich dann wie es
weitergeht
als nächstes werde ich gleich die
streusel zubereiten das sehe ich jetzt
einfach vor weil der thermomix sowieso
schon mit teig verschmutzt ist
und da müsst ihr es nicht zweimal
auswaschen für die streusel braucht ihr
130 gramm mehl einen esslöffel cacau 50
gramm zucker und 75 gramm butter und
staat so gebt ihr die jetzt einfach in
den thermomix und die werden jetzt zehn
sekunden auf stufe sechs vermischt und
so sehen sie dann fertig aus die fülle
ich mir jetzt einfach in einen anderen
behälter
die brauche ich nämlich erst später die
streusel stelle hier zwang zur seite und
werde jetzt die füllung zu bereiten
dafür muss aber der thermomix einmal
ausgewaschen werden
ich gebe es da etwas wasser rein und
etwas spüle und zeigt und da ein
bisschen sauer machen
ich habe jetzt hier einfach ein bisschen
wasser drin und etwas spülmittel gibt
den deckel verschließen
und dann mag ich ein paar sekunden und
den rest kann ich schon aus spüren kann
dann gleich weiter mit weniger denn
tommys habt dann verarbeitet ihr den
teig und die sträuße ganz einfach mit
einem handrührgerät neben dazu aber am
besten die knethaken ihr könnt jetzt an
der stelle schon mal den ofen auf 200
grad ober unterhitze vorheizen und im
nächsten schritt zeige ich euch wie ihr
die füllung herstellen
für die füllung braucht ihr 70 gramm
zucker etwas zitronensaft etwa einen
esslöffel zitronenschale 300 gramm mehl
2 eier 500 gramm magerquark 75 gramm öl
und eine packung puddingpulver oder so
wie bei mir jetzt 40 g speisestärke dann
gebt ihr zuerst den zucker in den
thermomix und gibt da auch die eier mit
dazu
da kommt auch die zeit der zitronensaft
rennen dann etwas zitronenschale
da können wir einfach so hinnehmen wie
errichtet ihr wisst ja dass ich in
zitronen ich habe ihr könnt vorschlag
orangenschale nehmen aber eigentlich
passt dann zitrone bestand und wieder
kommt der deckel drauf und dann ist das
ganz einfach eine minute auf stufe vier
schaut gerührt
dann gebt ihr hier den cup mit dazu die
sich übrigens magerquark war zu mager
da kommt die milch rhein und die
speisestärke und so wird es noch mal
zehn sekunden auf stufe vier eingaben
zum schluss gibt jedoch das öl durch die
decke öffnung mit rein und wird es auch
nochmal zehn sekunden auf stufe vier
und so sieht dann die fertige füllung
aus die creme gibt die dann vorsichtig
auf euren vorbereiteten kuchen einfach
langsam über die kirche wer möchte kann
da auch noch vanilleschote hinzufügen
oder wenn ihr vanille puddingpulver
nimmt habt ihr das aroma drin
das habe ich aber grundsätzlich nie als
fertigprodukte das mache ich immer
selber schön dass alle kirschen bedeckt
sind
der kuchen wird jetzt vorgebacken bei
200 grad etwa 15 minuten und danach
kommen dann erst die streusel drauf und
dann wird es schließlich fertig gebracht
nach einer viertelstunde im ofen ca teil
kuchen nun so aus jetzt verteile ich da
noch schön die streusel drüber
ganz vorsichtig
zu den kuchen das rezept habe ich selber
gemacht und habe es jetzt auch schon
öfter nach gebacken und eigentlich kommt
da echt immer gut also jedem schmeckt
akuten jeder der kirschen mag jeder der
käsekuchen mag und es geht einfach
unheimlich schnell noch mal für 25
minuten in den ofen und wird fertig
gebacken und dann aus wenn er aus dem
ofen kommt ich werde jetzt einfach in
der form auskühlen lassen wehrt ihn
jetzt über nacht mit einem tuch bedecken
dass da nichts dran kommt und da wird
dann einfach morgen gegessen ich denke
da schmeckt auch einfach am besten wenn
ihr den einfach in der nacht kühl stellt
oder einfach bei zimmertemperatur stehen
lässt falls ihr denn am gleichen tag
noch essen wollen lasst ihn einfach
auskühlen bisher ganz kritisch und dann
kann er schon gegessen werden ich hoffe
dieses einfache und schnelle rezept
gefällt euch ich werde euch morgen früh
dann noch mal zeigen wie ich den kuchen
abschneide
das mache ich aber dann einfach im
schnelldurchlauf
da kann ich mich nämlich jetzt schon
verabschieden ich wünsche euch auf jeden
fall viel spaß beim nachbacken in guten
appetit beim probieren und essen und
dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
wieder zu meinem nächsten video bis bald